Zain is a dangerous fellow who likes to
go rock climbing inside an active
volcano he is a dangerous fellow he just
heard some rumbling so he's decided to
climb out as quickly as he can
Zane's elevation relative to the edge of
the inside of the volcano in meters II
as a function of time in seconds is
shown in the table below
Zane climbs at a constant rate so this
guy I mean if we were to draw a volcano
here I mean this guy is just kind of you
know he's kind of silly so this is this
is my my volcano and he is actually
climbing on the inside he's climbing on
the inside of an active volcano so
there's probably you know there's
probably smoke and ash and all the other
stuff coming out of this thing so this
really is this really is dangerous for
him and let's say that this right over
here is Zane maybe and he's climbing up
he's climbing up from inside the active
volcano so let's think of what what
let's think about what they're telling
us so based on the table which of these
statements is true so I'm not going to
even look at the statements here I'm
just going to try to interpret this so
at time equals so it is so his elevation
as a function of time in seconds is
shown in the table below
so this elevation is negative 24 when
time is equal to zero and this table is
done in a kind of a non-traditional way
normally we would have the input into
the function on the left hand side and
then we would have the we would have the
function of it on the right hand side
and actually I like looking at things
that way so I'm going to make it like
that so let me let me copy and paste
this so I can put on the other side so
let me cut and let me paste it paste it
right over here so this one now I can
think of it a little bit clearer so at
time zero he's going to be at negative
24 meters at time 4 seconds he's going
to be at negative 21 meters so this
makes it a little bit clearer at least
in my head at least in my head so let's
think about what's happening so where
does he start at time equals zero where
is he
well time equals zero he's 24 meters
below the edge of the volcano so this
distance at time equals zero
this distance right over here is 24
meters and we could even plot this in a
graph so let's say so this is his this
is his elevation relative to the edge
and it is a function of time I'll write
it like that and it is negative most of
this time so I'm going to make the
x-axis a little or I should say the T
axis a little bit higher so look
something something like that that's our
T axis and when T is equal to zero we
see that his elevation is negative 24
meters so his elevation is negative 24
meters so he's going to this is right
here at 0 seconds and then when time
increases by 4 so our change in time is
equal to 4 what's his change in
elevation
well his change in elevation is let's
see he's going from negative 24 to
negative 21 he increased by 3 so his
change in elevation is equal to positive
3 he increased by 3 so at what rate is
he increasing his elevation with respect
to time
well change in elevation is equal to 3
per unit so when his and that's 3 when
his change in time when his change in
time and remember this triangle just
means just the Greek letter Delta
shorthand for change in so change in
elevation over change in time is 3 over
4 so one way to think about this is that
he goes 3/4 of a meter per second 3/4
meter per second the unit's up here is
meter the unit's down here is second so
he goes 3/4 of a meter per second and we
can verify that the next the next little
cop the next row here we see our change
in time is 8 change in time is 8 so it's
twice as much time as past so he should
have gone twice as much distance if his
rate is constant let's verify that
that's the case so he went from negative
21 to negative 15 has changed he is in
elevation increased by 6 so change in
elevation over change in time is 6 8
which is the same thing as 3/4 so you
see that he has this constant change so
let's plot a few of these points so when
time is 0 is
elevation is negative 24 when time is 4
when time is 4 right over there
his elevation is negative 21 let's say
this it looks something like this
negative 21 and so his his elevation as
a function of time is going to look
something like this it's going to look
something like this and I haven't let me
actually draw a little bit more to scale
because we built one thing that we the
other thing that we do know is that when
time is 32 his elevation is 0 so let me
put that right over there when time is
32 his elevation is 0 so his elevation
is a function of time looks something
like this something like this and we can
plot other points there when time is 4
so 4 is going to be this 1/2 that's 1/4
so 4 is going to be right over there his
elevation is negative 21 so this is a
general idea he starts at negative 24
meters and he increases at a rate of 340
meters per second so what did these troy
which of these choices is correct
Zane was 24 meters below the edge of the
volcano when he decided to leave and he
climbs 3 meters every 4 seconds on the
way out that seems right he climbs 3
meters every 4 seconds so we're going to
go with that one let's make sure that
these aren't right Zane was 24 meters
below the volcano when he decided to
leave and he climbs 4 meters every 3
seconds no no it's 3 meters every 4
seconds so that's not right zyne was 32
meters below the edge of the volcano no
that's not right Zane was 32 meters
that's not right either